zusammen herzlich willkommen zur zdf
heute live euren ihren live stream zu
aktuellen ereignissen und diskussionen
es kann jetzt sehr schnell gehen das
sagte bankchef schahin heute und das
unternehmen will tatsächlich corona
impfungen mit seinem m rna impfstoff für
alle kinder ab sechs monaten ermöglichen
noch nicht sofort
es braucht noch studien aber ab herbst
könnte das klappen
ab dem sommer auch für 12 bis 15 jährige
das kommt an einer woche wo wir am
montag schon gehört haben nach dem
impfgipfel dass die in priorisierung so
schnell wie möglich aufgehoben werden
soll wenn genug impfstoff da ist die
bundeskanzlerin hat er den juni in
aussicht gestellt das klang für viele
jetzt erst mal nach einer ziemlich guten
entwicklung dass jetzt möglichst viele
menschen möglichst schnell geimpft
werden können
aber es gab auch menschen die finden das
nicht so gut zum beispiel die soziologin
michaela maler die hatte sich schon
letzte woche vor dem impfgipfel in einem
artikel darüber beschwert dass eltern
der zitat letzte rest seien und sie
hatte gefordert diese gruppe soll doch
bitte schnellstmöglich und priorisiert
geimpft werden denn wie würden
schließlich seit einem jahr die
riesenlast dieser pandemie tragen wir
diskutieren das heute mit ihr und mit
dem chef der ständigen impfkommission
thomas mertens über diese forderung
erfindet die diskussion nämlich zitat
seltsam und wie immer eure fragen und
kommentare zu dem thema an
zdf heute.de zdf.de oder in die dafür
vorgesehenen kommentarspalten ihres
lieblings streaming mediums ich versuche
so schnell und so viel wie möglich hier
mit einzubinden aber wie immer bitte bei
diesem thema verschwörungstheorien und
andere merkwürdigkeiten sophie
beleidigungen untereinander sein lassen
sonst müssen wir die löschen und die
arbeit können wir uns sparen
ich beginne mal mit frau maler normaler
ist mir in münchen zugeschaltet
die im trio risi rung soll fallen freier
maler warum ist das für sie keine gute
nachricht warum möchten sie das jetzt
doch wieder eine priorisierung da ist
und eltern quasi zuerst geimpft werden
sollen
liegt er jetzt nicht in meinem
ermessensspielraum
diesen text habe ich vor einigen wochen
geschrieben eigentlich vor dem
hintergrund dass die eltern eigentlich
alle kriterien erfüllen die von der
stiko vorgegeben wurden um in der
priorisierung der rolle zu spielen
eltern haben einmal über die kontakte
der kinder in kita und schulen viel mehr
kontakte als also vielmehr unvermeidbare
kontakte sagen wir es mal so als
menschen ohne kinder
das heißt eltern müssen irgendwie selber
zu sehen wie sie sich schützen können
weil eltern auch von ihren kindern dann
wiederum natürlich zu hause keinen
abstand halten können
auf der anderen seite müssen kinder
geschützt werden dadurch dass das umfeld
um die kinder herum sicher gemacht wird
gipfel sprach schon im januar von einer
coco strategie also wir haben ja auch
lehrerinnen und lehrer erzieherinnen und
erzieher vorgezogen in der priorisierung
damit eben die schulen sicherer werden
und die kitas und jetzt wäre es eben nur
konsequent zu sagen auch die eltern
gehören natürlich zu dem umfeld was
schulen dann sicher sicherer machen
würde und ein ganz entscheidender punkt
an der ganzen sache ist dass es in der
im stil positionspapier sogar heißt
darüber hinaus den personen zu schützen
die für das gemeinwesen besonders
relevante funktionen erfüllen und nicht
ohne probleme ersetzbar sind und genau
diesen punkt der systemrelevanz den
erfüllen ja eltern zu 100 prozent
aber da eltern seien eben kein bezahlter
beruf ist spielen sie in der
priorisierung keine rolle
aber das problem war ja doch auch jetzt
bei dieser ganzen in gruppen
priorisierung dass immer die beschreibe
da war es ist zu bürokratisch es dauert
zu lange bis das alles raus gefunden
wurde
jetzt möchten sie ja quasi eine neue
große sehr große gruppe dann damit auf
machen ich meine eltern sind viele
menschen in deutschland
wer das dich vielleicht doch irgendwie
sinnvoller dann nicht noch mal eine
bürokratische hürde einzubauen so
einfach zu sagen eltern geht so schnell
wie vor geht hat ja auch sagte zu ihren
hausärzten und lasst euch impfen
also erstmal bin ich ja nicht in der
position dass ich sage ich möchte die
gruppe aufmachen ich habe einfach einen
gesellschaftlichen missstand
festgestellt der dahingehend ist dass
eltern eben ihre relevanz eigentlich
abgesprochen wird wenn wenn sie bei der
priorisierung überhaupt nicht bedacht
werden weil man hätte ja theoretisch es
ist jetzt natürlich alles irgendwie
kalter kaffee weil die sache ist im
grunde gelaufen aber man hätte ja
theoretisch die eltern auch innerhalb
der priorisierung gruppen zuerst impfen
können also man kennt das zum beispiel
man kann sich das weder waffengewalt
schnell gewesen so viel impfstoff war
gar nicht da wie innerhalb der gruppen
also es macht finde ich auch keinen sinn
eltern und risikogruppen jetzt einander
gegenüberzustellen weil das sind ja
keine zwei sich ausschließen den gruppen
sondern es gibt in jeder risikogruppe
gibt es auch eltern und eltern sind
einfach diejenigen die jetzt seit einem
jahr wirklich so viel geleistet haben so
viel geschultert haben homeschooling
wechsel unterricht kinderbetreuung home
office gleichzeitig dann die psychischen
belastungen für für kinder und
jugendliche das alles müssen eltern ja
auch mit auffangen und eltern sind jetzt
an dem punkt wo sie wirklich auf dem
zahnfleisch gehen wo aber der rest der
gesellschaft jetzt gerade darüber
debattiert wer wann wo in urlaub fährt
und wer als nächster waren in biergarten
gehen darf alle geimpft wurde und wer
nicht und es ist halt einfach so dass
für eltern diese pandemie jetzt nicht zu
ende ist weil eben kinder noch länger
nicht geimpft werden können
auch wenn wir jetzt gute nachrichten
haben das dass die impfstoffe bald
zugelassen werden aber sie wissen wie
lange das dauert
von der zulassung bis wir dann in
deutschland den stoff haben und bis dann
alle kinder wirklich durchgeimpft dass
das dauert einfach und es für die ganz
kleinen kinder gibt es auch noch keine
man müsse ein bisschen aufpassen dass
nicht ich einander kommende diskussion
wann sollten kinder geimpft werden und
sollten eltern vorgezogen werden wichtig
ist wir stellen jetzt schon fest dass
doch kinder auch schülerinnen und
schüler derzeit von der pandemie
schwerer betroffen sind das sehen wir an
vielen ausbrüchen auch an schulen mein
kollege jan frederik fischer hat das mal
in einer maz für uns zusammengefasst
das geht derzeit vor allem für
schülerinnen und schüler
denn viele ort sind die klassenräume
leer der grund die bundes notbremse
diese sieht schulschließung vor und zwar
wenn region an drei tagen hintereinander
den wert von 165 überschreiten
etliche landkreise und städte sind
betroffen und dürfte es noch länger
bleiben denn der blick auf die aktuelle
corona karte zeigt deutschland ist
weiter inmitten der dritten welle die
inzidenz sind weiter sehr hoch allein 95
regionen überschreiten den wert von 200
blickt man speziell auf die werte von
kindern im alter von fünf bis 14 jahren
und damit überwiegend auf schüler
erkennt man die werte sind deutlich
höher
in 168 region wird hier die schwelle von
200 gerissen die deutlich höhere instanz
sie ist mitunter auch ein risiko für
eltern statt einem schul shutdown
wünschen sich einige von ihnen jetzt
priorisierte impfungen zu ihrer eigenen
sicherheit und damit schulen nicht
zwangsweise geschlossen werden müssen
und wir holen den chef der ständigen
impfkommission dazu thomas mertens
hätten sie haben gerade ja die bedenken
die forderung von frau meier gehört ich
werfe noch mal eine stimme aus twitter
ein dich heute gefunden habe von einer
userin die schrieb ein gutes jahr corona
mit zwei kindern im grundschulalter und
von aliens entführt werden ist auf
einmal eine option hashtag eltern impfen
können sie diese forderungen diesen
wunsch nicht nachvollziehen weil sie
mich ja also zunächst muss man aber die
dinge ein bisschen sortieren
es ging ja doch einiges durcheinander
erstens müssen doch lernen alle zwischen
infektion und erkrankung zu
unterscheiden das ist ein ganz
wesentlicher unterschied
der grund der priorisierung bei sehr
knappen impfstoff war dass man dieses
knappe gut so verteilen wollte dass die
schwächsten in der gesellschaft
geschützt werden und die geschwächten
waren zunächst definiert als die die ein
sehr hohes risiko für eine schwere
erkrankung haben und weniger die die ein
risiko für infektionen haben
wenn wir also mal diese unterscheidung
vergegenwärtigen dann versteht man
glaube ich relativ leicht warum man
zuerst die menschen und zwar nicht nur
die alten menschen sondern die menschen
mit vorerkrankungen schützen wollte
damit die nicht die gefahr haben sehr
schwer zu erkranken und damit auch ins
krankenhaus zu kommen und zu versterben
das ist etwas was mit dem deutschen
ethikrat der leopoldina und der stiko
eben ja schon vor der ersten empfehlung
vereinbart und auch schriftlich
niedergelegt worden ist also das war das
hauptkriterium der schutz von menschen
in dieser gesellschaft die ein hohes
risiko für schwere erkrankung aber da
sehen wir ja jetzt herr mertens wenn wir
mal kurz bei dem aspekt bleiben dass
vermehrt sich junge menschen auf
intensivstationen befinden das berichtet
die die wie wir haben zum beispiel ärzte
wie kam in scheiben bogen die
beschäftigt sich mit menschen die mit
chronischer müdigkeit leiden die sagt in
einem interview dass sie mehr junge
menschen bei sich hat die jetzt
tatsächlich an longo wird effekten und
an diesem an diesen symptomen leiden
also dann kann man doch auch feststellen
wir haben auch da ein gewisses risiko
dass menschen an einer
profit erkrankung noch länger zu tun
haben vielleicht nicht unbedingt sterben
aber zumindest doch sehr lange darunter
leiden müssen
ja aber dennoch werden sie zunächst ein
knappes gut haben dann müssen die
schützen und ich habe ja nicht gesagt
dass es sich und die alten menschen
angriff sondern es handelt sich um die
alten einerseits und und die menschen
mit schweren vorerkrankungen
andererseits also diabetiker alles das
ist ja x-fach durch die presse gegangen
das brauchen wir jetzt nicht zu
wiederholen
ich habe danach die haben sie so
genannten systemrelevanten und da sagt
ja frau maler wir sind auch
systemrelevant als eltern wir sind nicht
so dass die systemrelevanten wenn sie
von den lehrern sprechen dann wissen ja
genau das die nicht entsprechend der
stiko gemischt worden sind sondern die
sind durch politischen willen vorgezogen
worden also das war ja die stand nicht
so hoch in der spitze priorisierung ich
möchte mal aber kurz noch den aspekt der
gerechtigkeit mit einfügen in dieser
gesellschaft der spielt ja hier auch
eine große rolle sie es gibt noch sehr
viele menschen die aufgrund von schweren
vorerkrankungen und zum teil auch
tatsächlich noch auf alter ein solches
risiko für eine schwere kost 19 kranken
haben und ich würde es für nicht gerecht
halten wenn man jetzt die spielregeln
ändert und die den menschen sagt die zum
teil ja sehr ruhig und auch mit geduld
auf ihre impfung gewartet haben jetzt
sozusagen dieses recht bald eine impfung
zu bekommen nehmen würde und das ist der
grund warum ich wie sie mich zitiert
haben die diskussion um die
priorisierung als seltsam
charakterisiert habe formaler wollen sie
sich vordringen
ich habe jetzt so viele zuschriften
bekommen und bin ständig im dialog mit
eltern und ich glaube ich wirklich alle
darüber einig sind dass es hier
überhaupt nicht darum geht das jetzt
menschen mit vorerkrankungen oder ältere
menschen oder wie auch immer
deswegen ins hintertreffen geraten
sollen dann im gegenteil wie gesagt die
der vorschlag war ja innerhalb der
gruppen zu priorisieren das heißt eine
mutter mit einer schweren vorerkrankung
vor einer person mit schweren
vorerkrankungen zu impfen die zum
beispiel keine kinder hat weil die diese
mutter halt eben auch noch kinder zu
versorgen hat und deswegen wäre es
sozusagen noch fataler wenn ihr etwas
zustößt und der andere punkt ist
natürlich sie sagen jetzt hohes alter
vorerkrankungen und so weiter aber wir
sind jetzt mittlerweile an dem punkt in
der imf reihenfolge angekommen wo wir
die imw gruppe 1 durch haben und wo wir
mit der in gruppe 2 fast durch sind und
viele ort mit der imw gruppe 3 begonnen
wird und hier haben wir eben ganz viele
sozusagen system relevante gruppen die
favorisiert geimpft werden also wir
hatten heute irgendwie gerade die
diskussion auf twitter es ging um steuer
beraterinnen es ging um anwältinnen
personen der rechtspflege das sind das
sind alles personen die jetzt aufgrund
der priorisierung in der dritten gruppe
sozusagen denen relevanz zugesprochen
wird und den eltern wird es nicht obwohl
man die eltern ja eigentlich gar nicht
separat behandeln müsste sondern man
könnte sie ja innerhalb der gruppen man
kann sich das vielleicht auch ganz
bildhaft vorstellen wie am flughafen wo
einfach die eltern mit kleinen kindern
vor geholt werden und zuerst einsteigen
dürfen
so könnte man das doch auch innerhalb
der gruppen machen das einfach die
risikogruppen mit brio drei die jetzt ja
an steht sozusagen mit kindern vorher
vorher impft und sozusagen danach die
dementsprechenden und genauso könnte man
es auch in der letzten rest gruppe
machen dass man eben auch wieder erst
die eltern impft und dann menschen die
eben keine kinder zu versorgen
und keine private sage arbeit leisten
müssen
ja wir haben es haben sich in
berufsgruppen die berufsgruppen die sie
genannt haben alle diese berufsgruppen
zu kommen in der stimme überhaupt nicht
vor
es gibt keine priorisierung für
rechtsanwälte rechtspfleger und das ist
doch was sie sagen hat mit der
priorisierung empfehlung der stiko
eigentlich nichts zu tun wir hören sie
dann also wie wollen sie das denn ordner
finden sie das in ordnung oder am besten
dass wir jetzt einfach sagen wir impfen
so schnell wie möglich alle die als
erster hier schreien nein auf keinen
fall ich habe ja immer gesagt und ich
sage das jetzt auch wieder
ich denke dass wir das erst machen
können wenn zwei dinge erfüllt sind
nämlich den menschen die am dringendsten
eine info brauchen und ich betone am
dringendsten zunächst mal zum schutz vor
erkrankung und die eine impfung
angeboten bekommen haben und dann muss
auch eben ausreichend impfstoff seien
und noch eins es ist ja ganz klar dass
die priorisierung überhaupt nur so lange
gilt und auch nur solange sinn macht wie
es wenig impfstoff gibt in dem
augenblick wo es ausreichend impfstoff
gibt dann kann ja gar kein zweifel
darüber bestehen dass man dann auch
parallel die noch verbliebenen
risikopersonen und natürlich auch die
gesellschaft kämpfen kann und in diesem
zusammenhang sehe ich natürlich auch
eltern schulkinder wenn das dann möglich
sein wird das ist aus meiner sicht gar
kein problem aber ist das tatsächlich so
herr mertens mal wenn ich mir anschaue
was hausärzte berichten was das
sprechstundenhilfen berichten die sagen
bei uns stapeln sich die anfragen ich
komme da nicht mehr hinterher wir haben
kein system die wir das anders
organisieren sollen wir sind quasi
gerade nur noch terminverwaltung dass
das wird sich ja jetzt im juni auch
genau so ergeben und wenn man quasi das
noch mal so eine gruppe einführen würde
und sein okay eltern mit kindern bis
sechs jahren die können wir vorziehen
dann werden sich die anderen ja gar
nicht verstopfen die leitungen noch mal
alles das was sie gesagt haben über die
durchführung der impfung und die
umsetzung der impfempfehlung hat auch
wiederum und darauf muss ich schon
bestehen nichts mit der stiko zu tun
sie wissen die stiko machte empfehlungen
und ich halte diese empfehlung immer
noch für sehr sinnvoll und die umsetzung
dieser
empfehlungen nicht ausschließlich
normalerweise in der hand der länder und
in diesem fall ausnahmsweise auch in der
hand des bundesministeriums für
gesundheit weil die nämlich die
rechtsverordnung gelassen haben und auch
da geht immer wieder einiges
durcheinander
also ich kann den sicher sagen dass aus
der stiko empfehlung noch sehr viele
menschen die ein dringend eine impfung
benötigen und von dem er formal richtig
gesagt hat dass sie sehr auf jeden fall
auch bekommen haben dass sie die info
noch nicht bekommen haben und in diesem
zusammenhang ist es sehr schwer jetzt
unterscheiden zwischen was sie als
vordrängeln bezeichnen und sozusagen den
ansprüchen ich kann ihnen sagen seit
monaten ach ich seit einem jahr 50
meinen schreibtisch und der vieler
anderer leute mit ab mit mehr oder
weniger bösen briefen von menschen die
alle sagen ich muss priorisiert ja das
sind die bestimmte einzelhändler gruppen
also sie können sich das gar nicht
vorstellen wer alles in unserem land das
gefühl hat dringend priorisiert zu
werden wir werden zu müssen dass uns
daher dass das kann ich auch bestätigen
also ich habe jetzt hier wortmeldungen
bei uns im chat zum beispiel von mir
fällt ein name was für ein user name auf
youtube was soll das bringen jede
berufsgruppe möchte schnell geimpft
werden egal ob es lehrer einzelhandel
sportvereine und so weiter sind also
auch eltern aber im moment gibt es nicht
genug impfstoff für alle so dass wenn
eine gruppe vorgezogen wird eine andere
gruppe später geimpft wird eine perfekte
lösung gibt es nicht und eine frage an
sie formaler von katies timo glock warum
sollten eltern systemrelevanter sein als
kinderlose aber arbeitende menschen
so geht's schon los genau das ist
einfach eigentlich sehr einfach zu
beantwortende frage weil eltern 24
stunden am tag unbezahlte sorge arbeit
leisten und wenn eltern nicht gäbe dann
gibt es auch keine gesellschaft mehr
dann gibt es niemanden der den nachwuchs
großzieht der den nachwuchs zu
kompetenten intelligenten menschen macht
die dann später wieder in der
gesellschaft wichtige funktionen
erfüllen also eltern leisten eben genau
diese art
die aber einfach unsichtbar ist und das
ist eigentlich auch genau die die
kernthese in meinem text eltern sind der
letzte rest dass das von der
gesellschaft einfach nicht gesehen wird
und das spiegelt sich eben genauso in
solchen kommentaren und das spiegelt
sich auch eben in der impf priorisierung
dass diese relevanz nicht beachtet wird
weil vermehrten sie haben gesagt das hat
jetzt alles nichts mit der stiko tun das
mag sein aber wir führen ja die debatte
jetzt nicht als angriff auf die stiko
das mag also ich finde ich habe mir den
stufenplan angeguckt und der sieht ja
auch super aus und der sie ist auch
sieht auch besser aus eigentlich als das
was in der nationalen impfverordnung
dann daraus gemacht wurde weil zum
beispiel auch menschen in prekären
arbeit zu den lebensverhältnissen die
sind eigentlich wieder unter den tisch
gefallen das war etwas was von der stiko
vorgesehen war als priorisierung grund
und ich sage es jetzt aber nochmal wenn
man soll nicht die die risikogruppen und
die menschen in prekären
arbeitssituationen usw
als gegenpol zu den eltern den eltern
wollen sich da nicht folgt drängen
sondern eltern sind auch risikogruppen
und eltern arbeiten wir auch in solchen
berufen
was ist denn da passiert das dass die
politik sich quasi nicht
hundertprozentig an ihre empfehlungen
gehalten hat noch ein satz muss ich
sagen würde der risikogruppen sagen dann
müssen wir gleich sagen risiko für und
ich sagte des alleingangs weil das so
wichtig ist wir müssen unterscheiden
zwischen risikogruppe für erkrankung und
risikogruppe für infektionen
das gerät immer wieder in vergessenheit
und auch da muss man eine priorisierung
in dem sinne durchführen dass man
zunächst die risikogruppen für
erkrankungen geimpft weil das sind die
schwächsten in der gesellschaft
und jetzt zu ihrer frage also das kann
ich ihnen nicht genau beantworten aber
die politik hat natürlich viele gedanken
wenn sie eine empfehlung umsetzen und
ich selbst bin auch nicht glücklich
gewesen immer wie das gelaufen ist das
kann ich ihnen versichern und ich habe
mich ja dazu auch oft zu wort gemeldet
die stiko andererseits musste natürlich
bei all ihren empfehlungen sich auf
irgendeine daten auf daten stützen und
das sind bei uns nun mal
wissenschaftliche daten die aus studien
internationalen studien hervor gehen und
die uns erlauben die einteilung die
reihung der zu impfenden aufgrund
solcher nachprüfbaren daten zu warten
denn in dem augenblick wo wir sozusagen
auf zuruf das ändern und ich sagte ihm
ja und sie sagen dasselbe alle
gesellschaftlichen gruppen haben
irgendwann geschrieben dass sie drängt
jetzt bevorzugt geimpft werden müssten
aber man fordere ich einfach dass man
auch die entsprechenden daten dazu
liefert und nicht nur sozusagen die
hypothese formuliert diese oder jene
gruppe das bin ich jetzt gar nicht auf
die eltern bezogen wissen die hat ein
höheres recht weil das ist furchtbar
leicht so etwas zu formulieren aber die
stiko war ja total aufs glatteis begeben
wenn sie anfangen würde auf zuruf ihre
empfehlung zu ende wir haben das nicht
getan das hat mir viele böse briefe von
lehrern erziehern eingetragen das kann
ich ihnen versichern weil ich eben auch
gesagt habe wenn die kein zusätzliches
erkrankungsrisiko haben und die menschen
die und das gilt für die eltern und für
alle erwachsenen auch die ein
gesundheitsrisiko haben die sind ja
schon priorisiert hier geht es also um
ausschließlich um ansonsten erwachsenen
menschen ohne zusätzliche sollen sich
dass das tückische ist auch herr mertens
dass diese krankheit natürlich vor allem
auch leute leute schwer beschädigt die
eine vorbelastung haben aber eben auch
leute schwer schädigt bis jetzt gedacht
haben ihnen geht es gut sie sind gesund
und haben gut das immunsystem
ich selber habe so einen fall direkt in
engen kontakt
das ist die assistentin von von meiner
tochter mit pflege grad die wochenlang
ausgefallen ist wohl niemand gedacht
hätte dass der jeweils was passieren
kann weil die ist mitte 20 also aber die
hat halt viel kontakte eben auch engen
kontakt zu kindern im kindergarten
gehabt also ist das tatsächlich so eine
gute idee gewesen einfach nur zu gucken
ich gucke auf die vorerkrankungen
sondern musste auch die kontakte gucken
und wie hoch ist die mobilität der
einzelnen personen haben als sie haben
das vergessen was sie selbst gesagt
haben gerade das ganze ist ja wichtig
wenn wenig impfstoff da ist und ich
bleibe dabei wenn sie wenig impfstoff
haben der verteilt werden muss und ich
bitte das auch zu bedenken
dann müssen sie auch in dieser
priorisierung der reihenfolge
erstens auf der einen seite bedenken
dass sie wenig impfstoff da ist und auf
der anderen seite versuchen zu
identifizieren die das sozusagen
erwiesenermaßen höchste risiko haben
hier stehen sie ich hab ja überhaupt
nichts dagegen dass eltern geben es
werden wie sollte ich bin vierfacher
vater und mehrfacher großvater also es
macht überhaupt keinen sinn
ich glaube natürlich müssen auch eltern
geben aber es geht doch hier um die
frage wer muss zuerst geimpft werden
wenn von dem impfstoff nur sehr wenig da
ist und das muss man mal sozusagen sich
klar machen und ich glaube nicht dass in
dieser situation es ist sehr wenig
impfstoff da wir fangen an zu impfen
jetzt gesunde eltern und auch kinder
wirklich die erste priorität haben
können denn dann würden sozusagen alle
anderen die ein hohes risiko haben
sterben einfach und das können wir doch
als gesellschaft nicht wollen also ich
glaub das ist noch nicht die forderung
frontfrau maler
ich würde ganz gerne mal hier nochmal in
die kommentare gucken einmal auf meinen
rechner schalten da ist ein kommentaren
von rom der meint ich glaube das thema
ist echt schwierig hier habe ich
markiert bei gerechtigkeit zu finden
nicht einfach ich glaube dass fast alle
sich nun freuen wenn mit rekordquoten
wie jetzt gerade geimpft wird bald liegt
hinter uns also das kann man fast nur
hoffen auch wenn ich da immer wieder
skeptisch skepsis höhere und wenn ich
mal die anderen kommentare angucke die
mir die redaktion so zusammengestellt
hat dann gibt es wortmeldungen wie
eltern seien das aber freiwillig
formaler andere fordern singles zuerst
die wollen am meisten neue leute
kennenlernen
es gibt aber auch dank an sie für ihre
forderung von alexandra helma zum
beispiel die zeit endlich spricht mal
jemand an was familien im letzten jahr
alles leisten mussten
und jetzt immer noch zurückstecken
müssen und klaus dirlewang schreibt per
e-mail eltern von schulpflichtigen
kindern gehören natürlich mindestens in
die erhöhte priorität noch sind aber nur
zwei drittel der sehr hoch
und ein drittel der hohen priorität
geimpft das variiert aber von bundesland
zu bundesland selbst personen mit 40
prozent sauerstoff austausch hohe
priorität haben noch nicht einmal einen
impftermin landkreis münchen
ich kann ihnen gar nicht sagen wie sehr
ich das finde das super jetzt schon im
mai die priorisierung aufheben möchte
eine diskussion die wir aber auch haben
und die natürlich auch wichtig ist und
die jetzt an aktualität gewonnen hat ist
die meldung dass wir vielleicht auch
bald kinder impfen können dadurch gern
noch mal darüber reden auch mit ihnen
herr mertens was da ihre medizinische
einschätzung ist wir schauen uns mal
kurz an wie bis jetzt eigentlich die
situation ist wir haben dann einen
kleinen beitrag vorbereitet gerade 17
und schon das erste mal gegen korona
geimpft felix uba hat eine chronische
darmerkrankung deshalb ist er schon dran
das hat lange große bedeutung für mich
noch eine gewisse sicherheit und ich
freue mich in der halle einfach nur
richtig
daniel foul kinderarzt in stuttgart
corona schwerpunktpraxis kann sich kaum
retten vor anfragen seit sich
herumgesprochen hat dass der impfstoff
bekommt für chronisch kranke jugendliche
werden wie mehr impfstoff gang zur
verfügung das natürlich wort noch
limitiert weil wir wollten nicht immer
unsere jugendlichen impfen auf 16
sondern eben alle honige nun gibt es
hoffnung auch für jüngere kinder bei
montech will nun die zulassung schon für
zwölfjährige einreichen in einigen
wochen bereits könnten die ersten
impfungen von schülern starten
studien mit kleineren kindern sogar
säugling laufen auch da sollen bald
ergebnisse auf dem tisch lägen
impfstoffe testen an minderjährigen
juristisch schwierig trotzdem werden an
vielen orten der welt fast alle corona
impfstoffe auch an kindern untersucht
kinder sind keine kleinen erwachsenen da
muss erst mal herausfinden welches die
richtige dosis für den jeweiligen
impfstoff ist und dann die
verträglichkeit sich anschauen
kleine kinder gegen korona impfen auch
eine ethische frage
fast alle haben leichte verläufe wozu
dann impfen ersten zwei kinder auch
anrecht auf impfschutz haben
zweitens weil es viele kinder gibt die
grundkrankheiten haben und die bei coop
19 erkrankungen die zusätzliche bürde
haben
und drittens weil wir uns in einer
pandemie befinden und da brauche man
eben auch die kinder sagen viele
wissenschaftler für den herdenschutz
doch manche eltern halten impfen ihrer
kinder für unangemessen
man sagt ja auch bei kindern ist das
weniger schlimm dann ist kann dies haben
dann denke ich mir sowas halt einfach
einmal durchmachen muss ja nicht so
häufig dagegen geimpft werden felix
zögerte nicht eine sekunde sich impfen
zu lassen er traut sich wieder unter
menschen mit der impfung kommt die
freiheit einstieg naja wie ist das bei
ihnen frei maler würden sie ihre kinder
impfen lassen auf jeden fall ja klar
und herr mertens das problem ist ja doch
aber auch angesprochen dass kinder
eigentlich nicht von dem schweren
verlauf betroffen sind trotzdem
kinderärzte fordern einen schutzring um
gerade junge kinder zu bilden weil es da
auch zu schweren verläufen kann es gibt
da ja berichte aus großbritannien wäre
das vielleicht so ein kompromiss auch in
medizinischer kompromiss dass man sagt
man muss die müssen wir auch schützen
weil es eben da zu schweren verläufen
kommen kann und kinder dann doch
besonders wohl nur abel sind gerade auch
babys also zunächst mal bin ich sehr
froh dass es demnächst problemlos
möglich sein wird die kinder und auch
die jugendlichen dann zu schützen durch
impfung die auch eben ein hohes risiko
haben also der dargestellte junge mit
der chronischen darmerkrankungen aber da
gibt es ja unendlich viele das fängt
jetzt schon an wenn die kinder mit
trisomie 21
die wir eben bisher unter einem
bestimmten alter nicht impfen können
oder nur wenn der arzt persönlich sehr
viel verantwortung übernimmt ich stimme
also mit all dem was uns einige gesagt
hat der übrigens auch mitglied der stiko
ist vollständig überein
eine frage und ich hoffe mehr als jeder
andere oder genauso wie jeder andere
dass wir bald so viel impfstoff haben
dass sich diese diskussion dann
weitgehend erledigt haben wird und das
ist das problem
ich sage es nochmal das problem war von
uns bei uns nicht die priorisierung
sondern das problem war dass wir in den
ersten monaten jetzt wirklich viel zu
wenig impfstoff gehabt haben das ist
ganz klar das ist das einzige große
probleme aber der sollte jetzt kommen
frauen insgesamt ist dann ist dann für
sie die diskussion eigentlich obsolet
oder machen sie sich trotzdem sorgen
dass wir ganz am ende erst dran sind
nur wenn wir den impfstoff jetzt dann
bald haben werden heißt es ja trotzdem
nicht das alle sofort gleichzeitig
geimpft sind ich meine wir sprechen ja
von seit weihnachten davon dass jetzt
mit den impfungen losgeht und damals war
schon irgendwie so der tenor
jetzt ist die pandemie vorbei so zu
sagen und dann haben wir aber gemerkt
nein das dauert das geht nicht so
schnell und es wird auch jetzt nicht so
schnell gehen
es ist immer noch die bundesregierung
spricht immer noch von herbst bis allen
impfangebot haben werden und es ist man
hat jetzt auch gerade bei den zuschauer
kommentaren gesehen
die öffentliche stimmung ist jetzt aber
schon wieder geht jetzt schon wieder in
die richtung die pandemie ist vorbei wo
können wir locker wie können wir unsere
freiheiten zurückkriegen und alle eltern
die sich das im moment anhören müssen
die den geht es dabei einfach nicht gut
weil eltern einfach wissen es wird mit
den kindern noch dauern das ist schön
wenn im juni angefangen wird kinder zu
impfen
das heißt aber nicht dass im juni
angefangen wird in deutschland kinder zu
impfen
und wir wissen von den erwachsenen wie
lange es dauert bis alle ihr impfangebot
haben und wie gesagt für kleine kinder
gibt es auch noch keine zugelassenen
impfstoffe
wie bitte ich wollte mich als andere
nerven drücken da wo sie waren noch
nicht fertig und deswegen ist es für
eltern einfach nicht so dass es jetzt
vorbei ist also wir wissen dass wir alle
mit unseren kindern jetzt den sommer
weiterhin zu hause sitzen und uns fragen
wie wir sie
dann können wir uns schützen können
genau mit den mit den mit der großen
mehrfachbelastung die wir als eltern
einfach haben weil wir eben nicht nur
für uns selber jeden tag die
entscheidung treffen mit wem kann ich
mich sehen wo kann ich mich so gefahrlos
mit jemanden treffen sondern wir müssen
das alles immer auch für die kinder mit
denken die kinder brauchen ihre kontakte
wir müssen immer gucken mit welcher
anderen familie können wir uns treffen
wo es ist vielleicht eine familie die
auch vorsichtig ist usw
das sind alles unglaubliche belastungen
die familien jetzt seit einem jahr
tragen neben diesen ganzen homeschooling
home office wba lasst den eltern da das
schultern müssen und einfach dieses
diese grundstimmung jetzt kommt bald
impfung für alle und wir gehen jetzt in
biergarten da können jetzt eltern
einfach noch nicht mitgehen und deswegen
wäre es einfach an der stelle eine
riesen entlastung für eltern auch wenn
es einfach nur ein monat ist oder zwei
monate früher wo man eine impfung
bekommt weil eltern einfach diesen weg
jetzt schon sehr sehr lange gehen und
also für mein empfinden zählt dabei
manchen jetzt wirklich jede woche aber
hafenstadt diskussion haben sie ja auch
schon gesagt ist im grunde ja zu spät
oder wird nicht mehr greifen weil die
politik schon gesagt hat wir heben die
in priorisierung auf oder sehen sie da
noch chancen dass wenn jetzt genug druck
kommt aus der bevölkerung dass sich dass
die bundesregierung noch mal anders
überlegt ich denke die beste chance wäre
wenn die hausärzte das machen und dann
was ja vorher auch angekündigt worden
ist dass nämlich die hausärzte dann
meine teilen den impfstoff keine rolle
mehr spielt also die menge des stoffes
dann würde es ja wieder auch an den
hausärzten liegen sozusagen die eltern
mit kindern zuerst dagegen spricht auch
meiner ansicht nach nicht dass die
meisten das priorisieren dann quasi die
müssen das priorisieren weil das andere
ist wenig praktikabel und ich glaube
auch dass das wenig sinn macht weil das
nur wieder eine natürlich sie haben es
ja selbst auch vorgelesen eine
zusätzliche gesellschaftliche spaltende
funktionen hervorruft und insofern
glaube ich dass es ein klassisches
problem was durch die ärzte gelöst
werden sollte und auch gelöst werden
kann und zwar auch sehr unbürokratischem
wege wenn sie so wollen die alm ist frau
maler dass sie dass man quasi jetzt die
hausärzte und hausärztinnen bittet bitte
sorgt dafür dass die die es wirklich
brauchen die kleine kinder haben die
auch wirklich nicht mehr können wegen
homeschooling und allem was ich
aufgezählt haben dass die zuerst ran
kommen das ist auf jeden fall ein
kompromiss ich habe ehrlich gesagt auch
die hoffnung aufgegeben dass jetzt von
politischer seite noch was kommt also
sowohl im großen kontext der pandemie
bewältigung stehen ja alle anzeichen auf
wir haben aufgegeben weiß auch was jetzt
die die fairness bei der imf reihenfolge
angeht also wie sie ja alles schon
gesagt haben die zeichen stehen auf
aufhebung der im freien folge bevor
überhaupt die die am meisten wohl in
gruppen geimpft sind stattdessen wird
jetzt über über impfen in den betrieben
und so weiter gesprochen und von daher
ist diese lösung mit den hausärzten
glaube ich das was wir jetzt praktikabel
am besten irgendwie noch hinkriegen
können dass wirklich jede ärztin jeder
arzt vielleicht für sich überlegt wer es
nicht gut wenn wir erstmal die familien
einladen und dann vielleicht menschen
die sich nicht um kinder kümmern müssen
und die ihre persönlichen kontakte
einfacher einschränken und verwalten
können
bevor ich das einmal eine letzte frage
stelle an herr mertens als wirklich
jetzt in ihrer funktion als chef der
ständigen impfkommission was die an
beyond impfstoff für kinder angeht noch
eine wortmeldung von peter pans per e
mail
geht an sie herr mertens erstens will
ich glaube ich nicht verstehen es geht
nicht darum gesunde eltern für
risikogruppen zu impfen
es geht darum wenn wir uns den brio
gruppe 3 befinden die mutter vor der
kinderlosen in der gleichen gruppe zu
impfen
bei einem schweren tödlichen verlauf bei
der mutter zusätzlich zu ihrem schaden
auch noch der ihrer kinder kommt das
würde ich erst mal so stehen lassen wenn
das okay ist für sie herr mertens und
die frage an sie richten können wir uns
dann tatsächlich dann jetzt auch
hoffnung machen dass dieser impfstoff
von bayer pfizer schnell zugelassen wird
auch für jüngere bevölkerungsgruppen
also meiner kenntnis nach ist das gerade
heute eingereicht worden jetzt also bei
der emea bei der fts ist ja also der
amerikanischen zulassungsbehörde ist es
bereits eingereicht und wenn ich richtig
informiert bin dann ist es auch heute
bei der europäischen zulassungsbehörde
eingereicht worden da dieser impfstoff
ja schon sehr gut bekannt ist kann das
nicht sehr lange daran bis dazu belassen
wird also ich würde mal sagen drei
wochen sollten eigentlich reichen das
würde tatsächlich bedeuten dass wir mit
der impfung von kindern und nochmal
gesagt dann würde ich das so sich dafür
plädieren zunächst dann auch wieder
innerhalb der kinder diejenigen zu
impfen zuerst ein wirklich schweres los
ansonsten trage neben trisomie 21
stichwort oder schwere grunderkrankungen
die es ja auch bei kindern geht also ich
denke auch dass wir bald das heißt mit
einem monat und es handelt sich ja wohl
gemerkt und den bayern dem stoff in dem
fall der uns also bei uns ja vorrätig
ist im augenblick also da habe ich schon
die hoffnung dass das in spätestens ende
mai juni losgehen kann
gut dann haben wir da zumindest eine
perspektive herr mertens formaler ich
bedanke mich für die diskussion ich
freue mich dass wir so eine art
kompromiss gefunden haben das ist ja
auch nicht selbstverständlich der ball
liegt also jetzt im spielfeld der
hausärztinnen die gucken sollten dass
sie das alles möglichst schnell über die
bühne kriegen auch da sie ich jetzt
schon diskussionen auf uns zu kommen
weil natürlich ist das eine zusätzliche
belastung
ich bedanke mich aber jetzt erstmal bei
meinen beiden gästen die schon
verschwunden sind von meinem bildschirm
außerdem natürlich bei euch und bei
ihnen für die kommentare und die fragen
und sage
stream wir freuen uns wenn er wieder mit
dabei seid macht's gut und tschüss